logan webb on the mound you see his team
record ronnie in the regular season and
the postseason here at oracle park they
have not lost a game logan webb has been
on the bounce can you imagine being 24
years old and starting game one in game
five game one was a gem looking for the
same here in game five well here is trey
turner now with bets at first base
turner on the ground got a man right
there
and that's how we get this game five
started and it's the opener corey knebel
has been an all-star closer with the
milwaukee brewers
he's opened four games this year this is
the first time he's ever done in the
postseason posey and second base here is
brandon crawford 3-2
crawford a swing at a miss knavel
strikes him out to end the inning but it
is the most wins
ever in a win or go home game with a
hundred
and nine a piece
on the ground
the stella down to a knee he'll make the
play will smith is retired justin turner
2-2 pitch
swing roller coming in crawford got time
here and he'll make the play for the out
and three consecutive ground balls
producing the last four outs so two men
are out here is gavin lux one two
and a cold strike three
red gets the corner and a one two three
inning for logan webb
so the wheels in motion for the dodgers
corey knable is out one inning the
opener now it's the hard throwing bruce
dark grouderal so now two on one away
for evan longoria
popped him up
bellinger drifting into foul territory
he'll make the catch and there is out
number two a big out for graderol
and now the pitcher logan webb coming up
bryant the runner at second floor is in
first and a swing and a miss and
grouderral
strikes out webb to end the inning we go
to the third in the giants nothing
dodges nothing well if you can have that
back he certainly would there's a called
strike three webb pours one in strikes
out bellinger on three pitches chris
taylor at the plate
oh that ball's hit well into left field
backing up on it is rough with room he's
got it on a cool night
and taylor is out one into the count
steven souza jr
and a wave and a miss down he goes
logan webb picks up strikeout number
three second time through the batting
order for logan webb corey seeger now
little tapper
and easy tag by flores that's does it
vanco
so there's out number one works like a
bun for seeger brings up trey turner the
national league batting champion this
season back to the bound webb will hurry
it over to first and there is out number
two
very weak contact by seeger and trey
turner
and mookie betts stays put at second
base there are two outs in the fourth
dodgers threatening now in the fourth
their best chance to score he deals
another little tapper webb calmly gloves
it throws it not a great throw but the
toe on the back for flores and that will
retire the side he threw a lob over the
first and a man on for chris bryant who
has deals and a swing at him as he
struck him out
julio
comes back to get chris bryant runner in
scoring position with one out and austin
slater
slater back up the middle
crawford on his way to third base turner
will take the shore out so two men are
out now crawford ends up in third two
and two
flores jam shot a little pop no problem
for trey turner and dorias is out of the
inning logan webb back to work bucks has
pushed it into a 3-2 count here he comes
and that's a call at strike three that
comeback sinker looks flailing out of
the way and then it just knifes back
over the plate
cody bellinger
a little tapper another one it's going
to be
another 1-3 put out webb's making more
plays than the rest of his infielders
another 3-2 and a swing the elements
went strikes him out came with a
fastball up and in
five k's for logan webb julio murias
back on the back
here it comes
and that is strike three call wow now
that is really a pitcher's pitch high
and tight
and one away for webb
and he goes right back to it so webb is
out three pitches a strikeout for urias
a scoreless game here's donovan salado
swinging out of miss who riaz just blows
the side right there
three up three down three k's is best
inning yet
one way
mookie bets who hits tonight rosie wants
a change up gets it bets was on it and a
base hit into left field rough is over
bets will turn and bets will stop at
first when mookie betts with his third
hit of the game
he's got all the dodger hits base
runners 10 for 11 and stolen base
attempts this year 100th here in the
sixth inning luffy will be a little more
aggressive bets goes seeker lets him run
pose his throw on a hop and not in time
lukey betts steal second base
and now the dodgers have a runner in
scoring position with one out we have
deals
and seeger down base hit
bets will score seeger on his way to
second throw comes in a belly flop
double and the dodgers score first in
game five
it's an rbi double for corey seeger and
it's one to nothing la in the sixth
here's ureas and the pitch to ruff
swinging a high drive
centerfield
it is out of here
and this game is tied
he finally hit one tonight that wasn't
caught
and he did it in a two-strike count 110
miles per hour over the 391 sign at dead
center
452 feet that homer was a moon blast
justin turner against webb who's still
in
it's a liner caught
solano makes a play goes down to a knee
so one away here in the seventh inning
in this one one game
and lux on the ground flores gobbles it
up
two outs
back door breaking ball 2-2 bellinger
swings and misses
logan webb
seven strong innings they love him here
in san francisco
2-2 the count would pollock the runner
in first
and that's on the ground up the middle
it's through for a base hit pollock will
stop at second mookie bets with a four
hit game
four for four
so bets is aboard what a night he's
having nine hits in this division series
two on one out for la here in the eighth
two and two rogers deal
swings and misses
and rogers comes up with a huge k
the dodgers have two men on
with two outs and you saw camilo doval
is in this game pollock the runner at
second
that's the runner at first no ball
slings one turner in the air right field
playable
this is going to get him out of the
inning and the giants hold serve one
pitch for dough ball so now two go on
here in the giant eighth here is buster
posey 2-2
posey swings and misses
kenley janssen
strikes out posey
in the ninth inning in san francisco two
men aboard go ahead and run at second
base and cody bellinger stepping in for
la
here comes the one two from duvall lines
went into right center field for a base
hit turner will score
lux is on his way to third bellinger
with the biggest hit of his career has
just given the dodgers a 2-1 lead what a
post-season for bellinger
after a lost season a bullet that finds
a hole they were playing them to pull
just hit it too hard and the hit by
pitch of turner costa violin giants oh
he has just delivered the dodgers in
front max surges in in a deciding game
tonight to pitch and close this game
on two days rest
crawford in the air to the left coming
in to make the play
taylor hauls it in crawford is retired
one away in the ninth inning from max
scherzer and the dodgers and [ __ ]
announced giants are going with lamont
wade scherzer fires and wade takes a
call strike three
ring him up max scherzer
strikes out lamont wade for out number
two
giants are down to their last out wilmer
flores no balls two strikes
and flores did he go he did
and the game ends
a swinging strike three
gabe morales rings him up the game is
over and the los angeles dodgers are
headed to the national league
championship series
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes